the following content is provided under  a Creative Commons license your support  will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to  offer high quality educational resources  for free  to make a donation or view additional  materials from hundreds of MIT courses  visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu  so I have this variable name once which  is um um Br  looks like people are getting it we have  a variable called repeat which is e ll a  and I'm creating a variable U which is  the concatenation of that with the  repeat multiplied by four so I think  people are on the right track seeing by  the 90% here it's going to give me this  result right here  great